yeah all right let's do it I'll ask you
to have a look into another lines and
some inequalities so at the top one you
don't have to do any manipulation
you just have to identify all right or
do we know where this is and which
direction to draw our line in as well as
what to do at that boundary point so
what do you think have we got the most
important point on another line there
we're cool I see the zero you've got the
boundary value there positive five so
that looks great
does the line go in the right direction
greater than so it's going that way
which tributing leads the direction this
inequality sign is heading in and we've
got a filled circle there is that the
one we're after cool looks good to me
okay when you have a look at this this
is what you had a look at yesterday the
strategies that you can use with
inequalities are very very similar to
the strategy you can use with equations
and that's why you can be asked to do
the same thing with them you're asked to
solve equations just like you're asked
to solve inequalities so you can see the
steps one by one can you help me work
out what's the very first thing that
Daniel did she added one to both sides
okay then from this line to this line
she has divided by 2
okay now will come to this point in a
minute which are which Jake added X is
less than negative 3 or 2 do you agree
with that we'd agree with fantastic now
I did say I did mention that you can
always use all the same strategies for
solving inequalities as you have to
solving equations with one exception
that you know about from yesterday to
remember what it was okay if you're
multiplying or dividing by a negative
number like for instance see how from
this line to this line we divided by two
if we have to divide by say negative two
which is quite a common thing to do what
happens to the inequality the a changes
direction okay so had it been this if it
was a negative at that point right when
you divide through by that negative 2
that's an X there this will become 3
over 2 but the recording would change
directions okay now something that
wasn't mentioned yesterday and to be
honest you won't really have to deal
with it until next year probably but
what virtually the same bourbon is
there's one other example of a thing you
can do to both sides that requires you
to change the inequality so for example
if I gave you this if I gave you this
equation right and I asked you can you
solve for X what would you do
if you write both sides as fractions
because the left-hand sides already a
fraction you might notice well if I want
X it's just the reciprocal of this
left-hand side so a common sense thing
to do would be well let's turn it upside
down which means you better turn this
upside down as well so you would write
this which is exactly correct you're
doing the same operation to both sides
both sides are equal so all good wicked
or but blacks if I said this when you
take the reciprocal of the left-hand
side like this and the reciprocal of the
right-hand side like this the inequality
isn't going to be going in the same
direction can you see why Jacob oh
you're going to say you're going to say
that let me give you a quick example to
prove this for you right let's think of
some numbers give me a number that's
bigger than another number can you two
dollars six is bigger than that one
doesn't want to go to market though okay
stick these are bigger than two right
now again if I do the reciprocals of
both sides is a six a six bigger or
should pick the different number is 1/6
bigger or smaller than 1/2 it's clearly
smaller right so multiplying dividing by
negatives you switch the direction
taking the reciprocal of both sides you
also switch direction lastly are you
happy with that number line yeah I do
think it's actually kind of nice to put
it in this decimal form or as a mixed
new rule because then it helps you work
out where it is in relation to other
things on the number line that's a lot
easier to work out where it is than that
but it's fine you could have labeled
that as - 302 who which is a dangerous
thing because that should be
- right watch out for that it is on the
correct side and we do have the hollow
circle which is correct I think what I
would like a little more than that is to
have that error on the number line a
that's a better way to go okay so if you
didn't do your audit on line and please
change that okay